- So Guemmy, you've given us a lot of tips
and things to think about.
Is there a way to just see where we are
in terms of our account security?
- Yeah. One thing I love
that's evolved in the industry
over the last few years
is a lot of the tech providers
have developed very simple
and easy to use tools.
Like a number of us have things
that are like a security
checkup for instance.
And it's a simple place where you can go
to be like, "What are the
top things I need to look at
to get my security better?
And what is the state that I'm in?"
Like for example,
some will give you a score,
you know, like your 99% safe.
Or you could have a color,
like a red, green and yellow.
And so it's really good to go into those
and see what specific
things in your account
that you need to go and fix.
- That's super helpful.
I have to say, I thought
I knew this pretty well,
and I do about 80% of what
you've been talking about,
but I have a little bit of work to do
to tighten up my my account
security after this.
(Sal laughs)
- Yeah, definitely.
And, and you know, like
a lot of companies,
including Google,
we do a lot in the
background automatically
to protect users.
And so when one of your services
actually tells you like,
"Hey, there is something
to pay attention to."
You really should,
because that's the last
mile that need to you to do
in order to protect you more fully.
- Super useful.
- Thanks so much Guemmy.
- Of course. Thank you.